taking a hit from uk sensors a court
battle with the howdy duty show and a
very real negative impact on our
ecosystem you won't believe the truth
behind the teenage mutant ninja turtles
the turtles made their first appearance
in may 1984 in the pages of their
self-titled comic co-creators kevin
eastman and peter laird self-published
their reptilian romp under the banner of
mirage studios a name they reportedly
chose because they had no actual
publishing company when the turtles
popularity began to boom alongside the
release of their first cartoon in 1987
archie comics launched their own comic
book series teenage mutant ninja turtles
adventures to capitalize on the show's
success the turtle's original mirage
series ran for two volumes a third
volume which was brutal violent and
largely considered by fans to be
non-canon was published under image
comics in 1996 the series returned to
the mirage fold for volume 4 which ran
from 2001 to 2014 a tie-in comic to the
2003 tv series was published by
dreamwave which only lasted for seven
issues idw publishing has also been
putting out a tmnt comic since 2011
which has had more than 250 issues to
date aside from their ongoing series the
turtles have also made crossover
appearances and comics published by
darkhorse boom studios in dc however the
turtles have yet to officially appear in
the marvel universe which is ironic
considering how their very first story
was written in a way that tied into the
origin of the hero of hell's kitchen
himself daredevil
any tmnt fan is familiar with their
origin story four turtles in the new
york sewers end up in the care of
splinter a martial arts expert who is
also a rat when a canister of
radioactive ooze falls into the sewers
transforming the turtles and their
master the newly mutated ninja warrior
names his four adopted sons after
renaissance artists and teaches them how
to fight however there have been at
least two significant occasions where
the crime fighting quartet welcomed the
fifth mutant turtle to their team and in
both instances that new member was a
girl the 1997 tv show ninja turtles the
next mutation introduced a major change
to the tmt mythos in the form of venus
de milo the fifth turtle venus
apparently mutated alongside the other
four but was adopted and raised by a
chinese shinobi master she wore a
braided light blue mask and was a
skilled magic practitioner she didn't
quite catch on in fact legend has it
that peter laird hated her with such a
passion that he banned her from
appearing in any future turtle
adaptations about two decades later a
fifth turtle would join the group once
again but this time a little differently
first appearing in 2015's teenage mutant
ninja turtles number 51 the idw series
introduced janika a former assassin who
was mutated into a turtle when leonardo
and donatello gave her an emergency
blood transfusion to save her life she
wears a yellow bandana and uses a pair
of claws evocative of the marvel hero
wolverine
the turtle successfully took the pop
culture world by storm in the 90s but
that doesn't mean the franchise didn't
have to make some compromises along the
way one of the most infamous examples in
the retitling of the series and the
replacement of one of the lead signature
weapons in order to make it past censors
in the united kingdom throughout the 80s
and 90s the british government was
particularly iffy about portrayals of
violence in various forms of media for
some reason the idea of the ninja a
stealthy assassin from halfway across
the globe just didn't sit right with uk
sensors that was why in the uk and other
european countries they were known as
the teenage mutant hero turtles the
show's name wasn't the only adjustment
that tmnt or tmht had to make for
british audiences though uk sensors also
weren't too keen on michelangelo's
nunchucks weapons strongly associated
with ninjas therefore michelangelo's
main weapon in the cartoon was changed
to become a grappling hook this
censorship rule also necessitated a
rather odd edit in the 1991 movie
teenage mutant ninja turtles 2 the
secret of the ooze centers mandated that
a scene showing michelangelo's swinging
sausage links as makeshift weapons be
cut from the final film an amusing note
from the sensors read reduced to minimum
dazzling display of swinging sausages
indistinguishable from chain
next time i'll sticks mustard
when the ninja turtles first jumped onto
the scene it seemed like the franchise
could do no wrong the cartoon was a
massive hit the movies made fans happy
and toy sales were off the charts that's
likely what brought about the idea of a
live concert tour sponsored and promoted
by pizza hut in 1990 the coming out of
our shells tour featured the four
turtles trading in their ninja weapons
for musical instruments leonardo was on
the bass guitar rafael was on the drums
donatello was the keyboarders and
michelangelo was the guitarist and lead
singer an actual band dressed up in
infamously bad tmnt costumes with denim
vest went on a year-long tour across the
united states performing original songs
on stage their first performance was a
live pay-per-view broadcast from radio
city music hall in new york the central
story of the musical tour revolved
around the turtle's nemesis the shredder
and his plan to steal the world's music
needless to say the coming out of our
shells tour certainly wasn't a highlight
of the tmnt fandom even though it was
successful enough to merit a smaller
follow-up tour in 1992
most people know chuck lorre for his
work on popular sitcoms such as roseanne
two and a half men and the big bang
theory however one of the lesser known
accomplishments of the king of sitcoms
was a major contribution to tmnt's
popularity he wrote the iconic theme
song from the 1987 cartoon in an
interview with indy wire lori shared how
three decades ago he and his co-writer
dennis brown were faced with an
incredibly short turnaround time for the
song saying we wrote it in an afternoon
and we recorded it in an evening at the
time
lori was trying to kick-start his career
by writing songs and scripts for tv
shows and was particularly interested in
the turtles gig someone else got the job
at first but when they didn't complete
the task on time the production team had
no choice but to contact laurie and give
him the assignment on a tight 48-hour
timeline lori and brown read the mirage
comics for inspiration then made the
most out of their meager two thousand
dollar budget by booking a studio in los
angeles from midnight until 8 8am
laurie also revealed that originally the
teenage mutant ninja turtles cartoon was
only going to last for 6 episodes he
said of the show's lasting legacy the
fact that the song still means anything
to anyone anywhere is just wonderful
it's become this phenomenon i'm very
proud to be attached to
the worldwide popularity of the tmnt
franchise has allowed for some truly
diverse interpretations of the
characters perhaps one of the best
examples was the japanese animated
special teenage mutant ninja turtles
legend of the super mutants also known
as mutant turtles superman legend this
two-part direct-to-video original video
animation was released in 1996 and was
created as a companion cartoon to the
metal mutant and super mutant action
figures the limited series also brought
back some of the voice actors from the
japanese dub of the 1987 cartoon legend
of the super mutants sees the four
turtles gaining the ability to transform
into armored super turtles through the
use of mystical gems called muted stones
their evil counterparts the shredder
krang bebop and rocksteady could also
transform using the muted stones with
shredder in particular having a striking
dragon-like alternate form further
strengthening the comparisons between
legend of the super mutants it also
borrows from tokusatsu's troops by
allowing the super turtles to merge into
a stronger entity called the turtle
saint the second part was even more
bizarre depicting the four turtles as
having the power to shift into elemental
animal forms through the use of mystical
suits of armor called metal beasts
the cover of marvel's captain america
comics number one features the sentinel
of liberty punching adolf hitler in the
face a powerful image that immediately
tells the reader who steve rogers is and
what he stands for interestingly enough
a teenage mutant ninja turtle had a
similar encounter in the comics one that
in the turtle's reality actually helped
put an end to the second world war in
issue number 64 of archie comics teenage
mutant ninja turtles adventures the
future versions of leonardo donatello
and raphael use a time slip generator to
go back to the past and stop a human
brain in a robot suit from wreaking
havoc they land in nazi germany where
they learn that the brain powering their
robot adversary belonged to the mad
tyrant himself a scuffle quickly ensues
during which the one-eyed future raf
gets the opportunity to deck the
dictator in the dome upon retrieving the
brain the turtles quickly open up a
portal to their own time but not before
convincing hitler that they're actually
brain-snatching demons in a vain attempt
to foil their plans hitler responds by
promptly pulling out a luger and blowing
his brains out
ask any longtime fan of tmnt to tell you
a single word that they connect with the
series and there's a good chance they'll
respond with one particular iconic
catchphrase
a nonsensical term coined by buffalo bob
smith for the howdy duty show in 1949
surfers began to popularize the phrase
in the 1960s there's no doubt however
that the turtles use of cowabunga helped
cement the term's popularity in the eyes
and mouths of the general public
according to david wise head writer of
the 1987 tmnt series he wrote cowabunga
into michelangelo's dialogue to give him
some added character but when the
party-loving reptile uttered the phrase
in the pilot episode it just clicked and
cowabunga became the turtle's battle cry
however this prompted buffalo bob to sue
eastman and laird for their use of the
term he invented they eventually settled
out of court for 50 thousand dollars but
due to its enduring popularity in the
tmnt mythos the phrase continues to pop
up in different on-screen incarnations
of the team
the most popular species of pet turtle
in the world is arguably the red-eared
slider their cheap price and
availability made them easily obtainable
in the u.s until 1975 when concerns
about salmonella negatively impacted the
turtle trade however less than two
decades later the demand for pet turtles
soared anew because of the tmnt
phenomenon and worsened a major invasive
species problem that continues to plague
the world's ecosystem to this very day
based on reports cited by the u.s
geological survey there is indeed a
direct connection between the tmnt
television cartoon craze as they called
it and the sudden boom in red-eared
slider populations worldwide u.s turtle
exports from 1989 to 1997 experienced a
staggering 257 percent increase as
thousands of children across the world
begged their parents for their very own
turtle pets at home there was a problem
though when young pet owners often
decided that they no longer wanted the
responsibility of caring for their
turtles they would release them into
nearby lakes or rivers unfortunately
red-eared sliders are infamous not just
for their tendency to carry disease but
also for being bigger and more
competitive than many native turtle
species when an invasive species is
introduced into a new environment it
usually spells doom for other species in
the ecosystem in fact invasive species
are the second greatest driver of
biodiversity loss worldwide
the seeds of the tmnt franchise were
planted in 1983 thanks to a random
illustration that kevin eastman sketched
while he was staying at peter laird's
place at the time they were working on a
different comic but the ridiculousness
of eastman's doodle a turtle wearing a
bandana and standing on two legs with a
pair of nunchucks strapped to his arms
made them reconsider their priorities
while the other turtles would come to
fruition soon after it was michelangelo
that started it all michelangelo is
often portrayed across various media
adaptations as the least serious among
the turtles the comic relief that
balances out leonardo's stoicism
rafael's ill-temper and donatello's
awkward nerdiness in most iterations
he's also the least skilled fighter
despite his tremendous unrealized
potential perhaps that's why eastman and
laird thought it would be appropriate
for him to be the lone surviving turtle
in a dystopian future story that they've
been planning since 1987. the 2020 comic
series tmnt the last ronin features a
much older michelangelo on a mission to
avenge his brothers after they were
killed by descendants of the shredder
armed with his brother's weapons this
michelangelo was violent fearless and
determined to take out the foot clan
once and for all there's something very
unsettling about seeing the class clown
in a different more brutal light aside
from serving as a love letter to the
various versions of the tmnt the 2009
animated film turtles forever made one
thing clear in every universe that has
the turtles there's an iteration of the
villainous shredder to serve as their
foil however this wasn't always meant to
be the case if the first ever tmt story
is any indication in their 1984 debut
the turtles faced off against the
shredder also known as orokusaki in a
rooftop battle that ended in his
off-screen death some time later the
villain returned to pester the turtles
anew resurrected by the foot clan in a
final showdown leonardo managed to cut
off the shredder's head seemingly
killing him for good but the shredder's
spectre would continue to haunt the
brothers however with raphael even
adopting the villain's mantle at one
point of course in virtually every other
incarnation of the turtles the shredder
has been portrayed as their main
antagonist nowadays many recognize the
shredder as the yin to the turtles yang
like the joker to batman or lex luthor
to superman not too bad for a guy named
after an office machine and covered with
glorified cheese graters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite turtles are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]